we can't make an accurate decision it's
all just hearsay it's all just this talk
talk talk no action I'll tell you what
okay you beat me in a pistol duel
you can upload whatever you want the
core Channel I'm sure if you're watching
with Channel you've probably heard of HP
dancer you probably heard of the
monetization and how you can be
monetizing channels they just released a
new content headlines if you read under
the surface a little bit you can start
to see what they're trying to do so I'm
sure you guys worked really with videos
that cry out outrage about in justices
and various things on the internet not
okay leave Raleigh together and put a
stop to it some of the stuff is cool
exposes things that are really not okay
like with Daddy of five videos those not
okay thing is those videos are super
popular it's a very easy way to get
views we've done even a touch of that
kind of stuff on our Channel those
videos get significantly more views than
other videos that we make now the
problem here is that this creeps a
monetary incentive for people to find
things to be outraged about people
create entire channels around the idea
of finding people and exposing them and
withing all the audience into a fervor
around these who are doing this
or that thing wrong and that's not a
good way to be doing this isn't the
court of law this is people on YouTube
it's very easy to create a witch-hunt
around something that then really
nothing bad has necessarily happened or
not all sides of story or no I don't
know if you've ever heard the term
yellow journalism but this is a
reference to the spanish-american war I
think of 1812 when newspapers would
print very controversial stories trying
to whip up fervor for the war and they
printed on a really cheap paper and that
paper kind of had a yellowish hue to it
or turn yellow after a short amount of
time basically what that refers to is
when people are writing stories for the
pure purpose of just getting people in
motional about something whether or not
the facts are justified whether or not
any of it's true it's basically the
outraged version of paparazzi and
celebrity gossip
you wanted to talk to me about something
regarding the channel you know how I've
brought up this whole thing about
combining the channels in the past
here's the thing okay yes some of our
core audience will hate it but most of
them most of them will appreciate it a
lot of channels have done this yeah it
works I hear where you're coming from I
just like having the two styles of
content separate corridor has style and
the same unique video tell us I really I
don't think putting the salmon eco
videos on the corridor channel would
really get them more views but that
think there's there's like a significant
number even if it's 10 percent okay 10
percent of the audience there is still
four hundred and twenty thousand subs
I'm going to be this how is the salmon
eco audience still growing well because
we're always trying to make you quality
content I mean I just don't think it's a
good idea like frustrating is you're not
allowing me to try it probably what okay
you beat me in a pistol duel and you can
upload whatever you want to the corner
channel gets better man adult those
videos no no there's a new ad guideline
assist inappropriate use of family
entertainment characters can be be
monetized that to me sounds like
YouTube's going you know what we love
the fact they're getting millions of
views and getting kids to watch YouTube
and they're hooked on the platforms but
we don't love the fact that we're paying
out millions and millions of dollars to
people for taking advantage of
characters are popular with you kids and
once again I get when they're coming
from the spider-man and Elsa videos are
really weird and showing kids opening
candy and opening toys over and over and
over and really not a healthy way to
make content for kids but when you're
making millions of dollars saying that
that's weird they're not it feels like
exploitation of children if you're
making content for kids on TV there's a
lot of laws that you actually have to
follow certain times a day you can't
advertise cereal certain times today
advertised food when kids are in shows
on TV they have to have a teacher on set
they can only work a certain number of
hours every day when those kids get paid
it goes to certain accounts you can only
manage certain ways and none of those
laws exist on YouTube so we expect not
to be censored online we expect to
create whatever you want to create but a
side product of that that you get people
that can exploit other people and you
get people I can exploit what people
want to watch let's be honest you don't
deserve that money we don't deserve to
add money it's a company that's paying
us put their ads on our content we can't
tell them they have to pay us if they
don't want to put their ads on our
content that's their call to make Peter
bring the dueling pistols
left or right all right so here are the
rule an impartial third party will say
what we will be sending back to back we
will start walking that impartial third
party will then stay turn when they say
turn you'll then turn and by our gum the
first one to fires our gun wins the duel
Wow anything I want
digging presents stéfan up you're not
telekinetic oh yeah Nick don't
you're gonna conquer it no dog that's
not my special technique my special
technique is shoot the other guy before
he shoots you to bed that nectars
doesn't work cuz my threshold is the
same technique well I do better yet not
since you're already dead Wow
I'll defend eco to the corridor channel
few friends movin you shoot me you're
fired weapons hold
[Music]
for
whoa Turner
[Music]
any warping we do we doing that guy so
it's the power you're defending the
combination of the channel
[Music]
haha
wah
[Music]
[Applause]
you know I think we can come up with a
different way to settle this
yeah you're probably right but I don't
want to
[Music]
you haven't already seen it go check out
our new gizmos up video rent let me do
some VFX on it it's a real good one hope
you like it
enjoy